stop the boat stop the boats three
defining words for this government but
the politics of migration illegal and
legal is divisive we welcome you unless
you come on a boat
and with record figures expected there's
cut through more and more are coming in
and you know they're coming in in
thousands you know and it's making it
harder for people like me to find
anywhere to live in marginal Tory seats
like thanet we Bridge are a little bit
too soft I think and is that illegal
migration or legal migration you're
talking about combination of both I
haven't got a problem with uh legal
migration providing it's done in the
right manner would immigration sway the
way you vote Yes I can go back 22 years
and they had a problem at Dover with
immigrants coming in why aren't the
politicians resolved it in 22 years that
I know of
constituents pushing policy in
Westminster do you think this
government's got a grip of immigration
well no I don't tougher rules on
immigration for overseas students were
announced yesterday that the right of
the conservative party isn't satisfied
Britain doesn't feel like it's really
working and having a net migration of
half a million year or more sounds like
the figures are going to be even higher
this week that doesn't help the
pressures that we all that we all are
all facing in just trying to get on with
normal life on Thursday the net
migration figures for 2022 are expected
to be at their highest level on record
they could be twice as high as they were
before brexit that is a problem for a
prime minister and a Home Secretary who
put immigration at the center of their
pitch to the public at Prime Minister's
questions today a show of solidarity
Richie sooner can swell a Braven side by
side as she survives why does he think
his Home Secretary seems to have such a
problem coping with points-based systems
PM deciding the Home Secretary won't be
investigated for trying to organize a
private speeding course avoiding a fight
with his own party and it's not clear
labor have the answers either do you
think it's a bit vague when you won't
say how much you want the numbers to
come down by I just think that you can't
set an abstract number like that because
who knows what can happen and then you
get you become a hostage to Fortune with
those numbers and I don't think that
those numbers helped at all um I think
they made the debate polarized and too
simplistic
but it is conservative disharmony in the
headlines the Home Secretary may have
survived the week the real verdict
though will ultimately come from people
in places like thanet Ali Fortescue Sky
News